Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。
Let's think today about presentations. Now, presentations are something which can be a big part of your journey not only as an aspiring psychologist but as a qualified psychologist too so when I was working in in the NHS most recently we would present you know information at multidisciplinary team meetings about clients or, you know, situations that we were working with. And it's important that you're able to get your information across concisely and in a way that helps the audience to, you know, understand what it is you're telling them and why, know what the outcomes would be so it can be useful when we're doing case discussions in that way to perhaps think about opening up with
今天我们来谈谈演讲。演讲不仅是你作为有抱负的心理学家，也是作为一名合格心理学家职业生涯中的重要组成部分。最近我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时，我们经常需要在多学科团队会议上，针对客户或我们正在处理的情况进行信息陈述。重要的是，你要能够简洁明了地传达信息，并以一种帮助听众理解你所讲内容及其原因的方式进行表达，让他们知道预期的结果是什么。因此，在进行案例讨论时，先思考一下如何开场会很有用，
what you're looking for from this situation this can also be useful for supervision as well. So certainly as my career has advanced, you learn to use supervision for helping stuckness. You know, there might be a specific question that you want to answer from supervision. So I would often, you know, begin my presentation, my communication with what I'm looking to gain. So, you know, I'm really hoping that, you know, out of today, the outcome would be that I find a way to work through this problem that feels a bit stuck. So I'd welcome your opinion on why this stuckness might have cropped up and what I and we can do with the client to help shift that and to have a different outcome. You know, the same is true in MDT meetings as well. So if I want something specific, if I want, you know, for example, a referral to psychiatry, or I would like another member of the MDT to think about assessing them, then I'm, you know, I'm saying. They can be weighing up for themselves whether they think that is a useful intervention, a useful next step. So it's always useful to have that, yeah, the direction of travel, you know, the intended destination as you are, as you're starting it and other types of presentations of course will include something
思考一下你从这种情况中想要得到什么。这对于督导也同样适用。随着我职业生涯的发展，我学会了利用督导来解决停滞不前的问题。你可能在督导中有一个想要回答的具体问题。所以我经常会以我想要获得的成果来开始我的陈述。比如，“我真的希望通过今天的讨论，能找到解决这个棘手问题的方法。”我很欢迎大家提出意见，探讨为什么会出现这种停滞，以及我和我们团队可以对客户做些什么来改变现状，从而获得不同的结果。在多学科团队会议中也是如此。如果我想要特定的结果，例如，我希望转诊给精神科医生，或者我希望多学科团队的其他成员考虑对他们进行评估，那么我就会直接说出来。他们可以自行权衡这是否是一个有用的干预措施，或者是否是下一步的有效步骤。因此，在开始演讲时，明确你的方向和预期目标总是很有用的。当然，其他类型的演讲还包括
a bit more powerpointy or a bit more canva-y I much prefer canva canva is so whizzy if you've not checked out canva yet then please do grab a link in my in my show notes. Okay, so why might you need to do a presentation as an aspiring psychologist? I hear you cry. Well, I have had a number of times when when I've been called to interview, I have been asked to prepare a presentation. And for some of you that may may leave you, you know, quaking in your boots and just thinking, no, I hate presentations. So what I'm hoping that we get out of today is to help you feel more confident, both in putting together your presentation, practicing it, and then, you know, smashing it out the park when you give it. I'm a little bit outside normal limits, because I actually really enjoy a presentation, which is
一些更偏向PPT或Canva风格的演示。我个人更喜欢Canva，它非常出色。如果你还没用过Canva，请务必通过我节目笔记中的链接去看看。好了，作为一名有抱负的心理学家，为什么你需要做演讲呢？你可能会问。嗯，我曾多次在面试时被要求准备演讲。对于你们中的一些人来说，这可能会让你感到胆战心惊，心想：“不，我讨厌演讲。”所以我希望通过今天的内容，能帮助你增强自信，无论是准备演讲、练习演讲，还是在演讲时表现出色。我可能有点异于常人，因为我实际上非常享受演讲，这
perhaps why I've ended up doing podcasts and things, because I don't mind speaking. You know, if you're in a group exercise and someone says, so who's going to feed back to the group? I'm like, I'll do it. I'm all right with that. People are like, oh, we've got Marianne in the group. She doesn't mind speaking. But there's, of course, something empowering about encouraging yourself to do things that might feel a little bit uncomfortable, you know, feeling the burn and doing it anyway. So let me help, you know, inspire you to be able to do presentations yourself so that you don't always have to ask the chatty one in the group to help support you with
也许就是我最终做播客等事情的原因，因为我不介意公开演讲。你知道，如果在一个小组练习中，有人问：“谁来向小组反馈？”我会说：“我来。”我对此没问题。大家会说：“哦，我们组有Marianne，她不介意发言。”但当然，鼓励自己去做一些可能让你感到有点不舒服的事情，去感受那种挑战并坚持去做，这本身就是一种赋能。所以，让我来帮助你，激励你能够自己进行演讲，这样你就不用总是依赖小组里那个健谈的人来帮你支持
that. So the first of my techniques is we're going to just put a little bit of structure together when we're creating the presentation. So what we're going to do is we're going to tell people what we're going to tell them before we then tell them it. So the first strategy is tell them what you're going to tell them. Obviously not in full detail, but you're just giving a little bit of structure. Even if it's a 10 minute presentation, you know, I'm taking people through what we're going to do. So if I was going to give you, you know, the plan for today's podcast episode, I'd be saying, you know, welcome along to this session on thinking about optimising your presentations. I'm just going to break down the structure of what to
这件事了。所以我的第一个技巧是，在准备演讲时，我们要建立一点结构。我们要做的就是，在告诉听众内容之前，先告诉他们我们要讲什么。所以第一个策略是：告诉他们你要讲什么。显然不需要非常详细，但你要给出一个结构。即使是一个10分钟的演讲，你也要引导听众了解我们将要做什么。比如，如果我要给你介绍今天播客节目的计划，我会说：“欢迎参加本次关于优化演讲的会议。我将分解一下我们
expect from what we're going to achieve within our time together so the um the way that that's going to look is i'm going to share with you um three um sections three top tips um to be able to you know supercharge what you're doing um and get the maximum benefit from it and then there's going to be you know i don't know there'll be an opportunity for questions um i'm then going to summarize what we've spoken about think about the main take-home learning points and then there will be an opportunity for questions. I'm then going to summarise what we've spoken about, think about the main take-home learning points, and then there will be an opportunity for questions at the end. So I hope you'll find this a really useful overview. Now, of course, as a one-way communication device of a podcast, I'm not going to be able to get your feedback on whether this was useful,
在接下来的时间里将要实现的目标。具体安排是，我将与大家分享三个核心技巧，帮助你们提升演讲水平并获得最大收益。然后会有提问环节。我将总结我们讨论的内容，思考主要的学习要点，最后会有提问环节。我希望你们会觉得这是一个非常有用的概述。当然，作为播客这种单向沟通工具，我无法获得你们关于这是否有用的反馈，
but that's the kind of thing I'd be saying in in a presentation situation for real so yeah we're telling them what we're going to tell them and for the next two tips I'm going to come back to you just after this break hope you find it useful useful. Come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAMS service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills but more than that it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories.
但在真实的演讲场合，这确实是我会说的话。所以，我们要告诉他们我们要讲什么。接下来的两个技巧，我将在休息后回来告诉大家。希望你们觉得有用。来看看这本书，就在这里，它是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家儿童与青少年心理健康服务中心（CAMS）担任助理从业者。我购买并阅读了Marianne的《临床心理学家合集》，在完成临床心理学培训申请的同时阅读它。事实证明，它真的是很好的陪伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在别人的故事中。
It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfill along the way because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic routes into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though, once you've started reading it's tough to put it down. guys filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified so come and take a look it's right here in this book it's the clinical psychologist collective
它及时提醒我不要太执着于最终目标，要珍惜并享受我们一路走来的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都有意义。它还让我确信，进入临床心理学的途径是多种多样的，这对我来说很重要，因为我走的是一条蜿蜒曲折的道路，而不是进入该行业的典型路线。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过要做好准备，暂时放下晚上的任务，一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训，所以来看看吧，就在这本书里，《临床心理学家合集》。
it's the clinical psychologist collective okay welcome back so we covered before the break we covered our first top tip for the structure of our presentations and that was we're going to tell them what we're going to tell them the second top tip is that we are then going to tell them we're gonna tell them the stuff that we're gonna we've told them we're gonna tell them this is a lot of telling isn isn't it? So I often think the best way to do this is not by putting all the information on every slide. That is the way to lose me. If you are standing in front of me reading what is on the slide, then I am going to be busy doing other stuff in my mind
《临床心理学家合集》。好了，欢迎回来。休息前我们讨论了演讲结构的第一条核心技巧，那就是：告诉他们你要讲什么。第二个核心技巧是：我们要开始讲了。我们要讲那些我们之前说要讲的内容。这听起来有很多“讲”对吧？所以我经常认为，最好的方法不是把所有信息都放在每一张幻灯片上。那是让我走神的方法。如果你站在我面前读幻灯片上的内容，那么我的大脑就会忙于做其他事情，
because I've already read it probably before you've started even talking. So I've gained read it probably before you've started even talking so I've gained my important points and it feels like there's less need to listen to what you're saying so when you're structuring any visual aids with your presentation I would make them look engaging I would have a key word or two on there if only to aid your memory of what you're going to say but do not put all the content in the slides and do not read from the slides because that is gonna lead to a zoned out audience especially in these um zoom times that we've got so if you're doing it via zoom you're gonna have people in the background playing on their
因为在你开始说话之前，我可能已经读完了。所以我已经获取了重点，感觉没必要再听你说了。因此，在设计演讲的视觉辅助工具时，我会让它们看起来引人入胜。我会放上一两个关键词，哪怕只是为了辅助记忆你要讲的内容，但千万不要把所有内容都塞进幻灯片里，也不要照着幻灯片念，因为这会导致听众走神，尤其是在我们现在的Zoom时代。所以如果你是通过Zoom进行演讲，听众可能会在后台玩他们的
ipads whilst listening to you and we want you to be communicating to your audience really well we want people to be really in tune and engaged with what you're saying and really wanting to be on board to learn what you're saying so So as you're talking, you might want to use any relevant references to help you back up your points, to demonstrate your theory. I often think even if it is, you know, for example, a presentation where you're talking about, you know, your clinical suitability for a role. So you might be talking about some work that you did with a client. I often think it's still useful to drop in the odd reference here and there, especially because you're, you know, you're striving to be
iPad，同时听你说话。我们希望你与听众进行良好的沟通，希望人们真正投入并参与到你所说的内容中，并真正愿意学习你所讲的东西。所以当你说话时，你可能想使用任何相关的参考资料来支持你的观点，以证明你的理论。我经常认为，即使是例如你谈论自己对职位的临床适应性的演讲，你可能在谈论你与客户所做的一些工作，我仍然认为在适当的地方插入一些参考资料是很有用的，特别是考虑到你正在努力成为
an academic. It shows that you are, you know, well versed in linking theory and practice. So that's another useful thing. If you've got, if it is linked to some outcomes that you did, it can be useful to think about, you know, putting together some graphs that demonstrate your progress with the client, demonstrate the effectiveness of whatever the intervention that you're discussing is. I'm a big fan of a beautiful presentation theme. So I used to have my go-to presentation theme for PowerPoint. But yeah, it's just a whole lot more beautiful and easier to to create in Canva. And you can still download as a PowerPoint from Canva if you need to, or you can just download it as PDF. So, yeah, just check out Canva if you haven't already.
一名学者。这表明你非常擅长将理论与实践相结合。所以这是另一个有用的技巧。如果它与你取得的一些成果相关，那么整理一些图表来展示你与客户的进展，证明你所讨论的干预措施的有效性，也是很有用的。我非常喜欢漂亮的演讲主题。我过去有自己常用的PowerPoint演讲主题，但现在在Canva中创建要漂亮得多，也容易得多。如果你需要，你仍然可以从Canva下载为PowerPoint，或者直接下载为PDF。所以，如果你还没用过，一定要去看看Canva。
Like I said, there's a link in the comments. It is ace. It's going to change your world. You can also put videos in there as well if you wanted to add snippets or jingles. You know, I love a jingle. So, yeah, thinking about engaging your audience and thinking about giving them something to look at, you know, something to listen to, which might those senses activated, you know, as you can to get them as engaged as possible. So we've told them what we're going to tell them. And then we've told them the stuff, you know, we've done it, we've told them it. And then the final point is we're going
就像我说的，评论区里有链接。它太棒了，它会改变你的世界。如果你想添加片段或叮当声，你也可以在里面放入视频。你知道，我喜欢叮当声。所以，考虑如何吸引听众，给他们一些可看的东西，一些可听的东西，这可能会激活他们的感官，尽可能让他们参与进来。所以我们已经告诉了他们我们要讲什么，然后我们讲了内容，我们做到了。最后一点是我们要
to tell them what we've told them. We're going to just briefly summarize what we've spoken about. And if there was any question for the presentation, so, you know, demonstrate how you used an intervention to alleviate the distress of a client you worked with, then that's the point where I'm going to be really drawing their attention to to the changes so answering the question that you've been asked now of course if there is a specific question that you might well pepper the appropriate words throughout when you're telling them as well from the middle section but this summary is where you're demonstrating that you're answering the question and you're doing it in a succinct time balanced way that hopefully is enthusiastic and not too anxious as a presentation style to watch. So I think it can be really useful to have a practice by yourself in an empty room with a
告诉他们我们讲了什么。我们要简要总结一下我们讨论的内容。如果演讲有特定的问题，例如，展示你如何使用干预措施来减轻客户的痛苦，那么这就是我真正引导他们关注变化的地方，也就是回答你被问到的问题。当然，如果有一个具体的问题，你可能在中间部分讲述时也会穿插适当的词汇，但这个总结部分是你展示你正在回答问题的地方，并且你以一种简洁、平衡的方式进行，希望这种演讲风格充满热情，而不是看起来太焦虑。所以我认为在空房间里用
timer on just to check how you're doing for time. And it can also be useful if it's a really important presentation. It can also be useful to practice that with someone else in the room so that you get used to people, you know, hearing the words as they come out of your mouth. You might, if that feels a bit too exposing or you haven't got someone to ask, you might find it helpful to record it on Zoom so that you can see what it is like to take away some of that eek moments that you might have about, you know, talking in public, standing up. So if you're going to be actually doing this presentation in person, it might be useful to just think about what you're going to be wearing, check that you're going to be comfortable, check that whatever you're wearing is going to help you bring your A game. It's going to help you, you know, like we
计时器进行练习是非常有用的，可以检查你的时间控制。如果这是一个非常重要的演讲，在房间里有其他人的情况下进行练习也很有用，这样你就能习惯人们听到你口中说出的话。如果这让你觉得太暴露，或者你找不到人帮忙，你可能会发现录制Zoom视频很有帮助，这样你就可以看到自己的表现，消除一些你可能对公开演讲、站立发言产生的尴尬时刻。所以如果你真的要亲自进行这次演讲，考虑一下你要穿什么，检查一下你是否会感到舒适，检查一下你的着装是否能帮助你发挥出最佳水平。这会帮助你，就像我们
said about the millionaire, you know, millionaire interview experience. We going to help you you know like we said about the millionaire um you know the millionaire interview experience we want to help you think that things are going well so your hair is looking like on point you're feeling good because we don't want any reasons to be feeling you know like we're exposed or vulnerable um at that moment So just making sure that you're, you're feeling, you know, good enough, ideally, about the situation that you're in when you are giving that presentation. So it is short and sweet from us today. But this is a special request, someone had asked me to cover presentations and how they're important and how we can, you know, how we can optimize and maximize them. So if you have got any specific requests, then check out the link in the show notes for how you can get in
说的百万富翁面试经验一样。我们要帮助你认为事情进展顺利，所以你的发型要到位，感觉良好，因为我们不希望有任何理由让自己在那一刻感到暴露或脆弱。所以只要确保你在进行演讲时，对所处的环境感到足够好就行了。所以我们今天的内容简短而甜蜜。但这是一个特别请求，有人要求我涵盖演讲以及它们的重要性，以及我们如何优化和最大化它们。所以如果你有任何具体要求，请查看节目笔记中的链接，了解如何联系
contact to nominate any podcast topics, because I want to make sure that this podcast is really useful for you, whatever stage of your career you are at. Thank you so much for listening. Please do come and connect with me on my socials, LinkedIn, Dr. Marianne Trent, YouTube, Good Thinking Psychological Services, Facebook, Good Thinking Psychological Services, Twitter, Good Thinking PS1, and Instagram, Dr. Marianne services twitter good thinking ps1 and instagram dr marianne trent thank you again for being part of my world and for listening right to the end we've just got a little bit coming up about the compassionate q and a series and then you can enjoy the jingle take care and like i said if you'd like to get involved with your own story for the aspiring
我来提名任何播客主题，因为我想确保这个播客对你真正有用，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段。非常感谢你的收听。请务必在我的社交媒体上与我联系：LinkedIn（Dr. Marianne Trent），YouTube（Good Thinking Psychological Services），Facebook（Good Thinking Psychological Services），Twitter（Good Thinking PS1），以及Instagram（Dr. Marianne Trent）。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分并听到最后。接下来我们有一点关于“富有同情心的问答系列”（compassionate q and a series）的内容，然后你可以欣赏一下叮当声。保重，就像我说的，如果你想参与分享你自己的故事，成为《有抱负的心理学家合集》的一员，
psychologist collective then do check out the details in the show notes for how you can request more information but if you head to my website which is goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and then head to my books there will be information there for you being well supported during any interview season is so important i have therefore planned some compassionate question and answer support sessions for you you are absolutely welcome to come along to all of them, some of them, none of them. No need to book and here are the dates for you. Monday the 28th of February from 7.30pm, Monday the 21st of March 7.30pm, Monday the 4th of April 7.30pm and Monday, the 9th of May, 7.30pm. And they will all be live streaming via my socials,
那么请查看节目笔记中的详细信息，了解如何索取更多信息。但如果你访问我的网站goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk，然后点击我的书籍，那里会有相关信息。在面试季期间得到良好的支持非常重要，因此我为你计划了一些富有同情心的问答支持会议。非常欢迎你参加所有、部分或不参加。无需预约，以下是日期：2月28日星期一晚上7:30，3月21日星期一晚上7:30，4月4日星期一晚上7:30，以及5月9日星期一晚上7:30。它们都将通过我的社交媒体进行直播，
which includes Twitter, YouTube, LinkedIn and Facebook. So you can absolutely pick your favourite platform and they'll all be available on replay as well. Hope you find it so useful. And I will look forward to catching up with some of you then. Take care. to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people
包括Twitter、YouTube、LinkedIn和Facebook。所以你绝对可以选择你最喜欢的平台，它们也都会提供回放。希望你觉得这很有用。我期待到时候与你们中的一些人交流。保重。祝你在获得资格的道路上一切顺利。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者培训生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们
got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始阅读，你就不会放下这本书。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。